Brian: We continue our series from Education Nation
tonight with the work of a remarkable young man who is
applying his three degrees from MIT and one from
Harvard to help a lot of young people around the world
do better in school.
His classroom, in this case, is the Internet and his
videos have become a teaching sensation from
Mountain View, California, NBC's Kristen Welker has
our story tonight.
(kids cheering)
Kristen: What makes 5th graders cheer?
Would you believe math?
Boy: Yes.
Girl: I'm starting to really like math now.
Kristen: These kids are learning with the help of
Khan Academy, an online school.
Adult: You got it right. Good job.
Videos that are interactive and fun,
explaining difficult concepts in a conversational way.
Khan: So if you want the slope of a line.
Kristen: Khan Academy is the brainchild of
34-year-old Sal Khan.
Khan: Everything in my gut says that's the right way
that education should move in the future.
In 2004, Khan started tutoring his cousin,
Nadia Rahman, in math.
Khan: So, this is it.
Kristen: She was out of state so he coached her
online from a closet in his home.
Now studying Pre-Med at Sarah Lawrence College,
Nadia says she has her cousin to thank.
Nadia: So I kind of, was able to learn on my own pace.
Kristen: Khan posted more lessons online for anyone to use.
The videos went viral and positive feedback poured in.
Khan: Your videos will allow us to help ...
Kristen: Khan eventually made 2,200 videos; basic math,
algebra, trigonometry, calculus, all for free.
Speaker: 9 divided by ...
Khan's lessons have been viewed on YouTube 43 million times,
Kristen: X equals zero.
Khan: You got it, very good.
Kristen: Yeah.
making them the largest educational source on the site
and he's attracting big attention.
Bill: I'm actually envious of the amazing work that he's done.
Kristen: We caught up with Bill Gates promoting
Khan Academy at this year's Tech Conference,
which focuses on new ideas.
Bill: It's phenomenal. It's the cutting edge of
where education is going.
Kristin: The Gates Foundation and Google recently
donated a total of 3.5 million dollars to help turn
Khan's not-for-profit into a global classroom.
Khan: Hopefully, Khan Academy will teach people
either there are no such things as geniuses
or that to some degree everyone is.
Kristin: A philosophy that is opening the doors of
learning all over the world.
Kristin Welker, NBC News, Mountain View, California.